[Musique]
chaque homme pour vivre pour faire
fonctionner son corps a besoin d'énergie
vous moi le réfugiés qui se trouvent en
syrie chacun a besoin d'énergie
la quantité d'énergie dont on a besoin
je peux l'exprimer en une certaine
quantité ces 25 centilitres d'essence
c'est l'équivalent énergétique que l'on
consomme tous les jours et dont on a
besoin
la société notre civilisation a
développé un ensemble de technologies
qui nous permet de garantir notre
confort et qui va en fait dépenser
beaucoup plus d'énergie lors d'une part
on va produire des déchets chacun
d'entre nous produit 2 kg de déchets par
jour dont 30 % à peu près sous forme de
déchets organiques qui est le résidu de
la nourriture qu'on a absorbé la
nourriture que la nature nous a donné on
va consommer l'énergie 5 litres de
pétrole par jour en moyenne en suisse
et le problème c'est que on le brûle et
on hérite du co2 14 kilos par jour 14
kilos par jour vous devez imaginer que
si c'était du solide vous devriez tous
les matins partir avec deux packs de six
bouteilles de dos et les mettre sur le
trottoir 14 kilos par jour
par chance c'est du gaz donc sa part
d'atmosphère on ne le voit pas on a trop
tendance à l'oublier mais il s'accumule
dans l'atmosphère
alors nous on ne sent pas les faits mais
tedx qui est là lui il observe déjà les
faits et on s'est dit que c'était
important de sauver tedx et de trouver
une solution est donc d'essayer de
limiter les émissions de co2 alors pour
ça il faut étudier le système
énergétique alors on a pris la suite on
a regardé où est ce qu'on consomme
l'énergie en suisse
47 % de la consommation énergétique de
la suisse est pour nous chauffer nous
éclairer dans les bâtiments cette
consommation énergétique est
principalement en hiver
en hiver il fait froid la chauffer et
principalement sous forme de chaleur
seulement 25 % de notre consommation
énergétique et sous forme d'électricité
le reste c'est de la chaleur assez 47%
je vais ajouter les besoins de mobilité
qui dépensent 40 36 % et le moteur d'une
société l'industrie qui elle a besoin
d'eux une vingtaine de pourcents faut
fonctionner le cari qui hélas est 100
litres d'essence par habitant et chaque
liste rouge est associé à une émission
de chaque carré rouge est associé à une
émission de co2 si on regarde la ville
elle a tendance à concentrer la
population on dit que à l'avenir et 1 75
% de la population qui vivra dans des
villes si elle concentre la population
elle va occuper l'espace à genève on a
par mètre carré
chaque mètre carré de surface au sol
correspond à également un mètre carré de
surface chauffée
ça veut dire qu'on va dépenser l'énergie
alors la valeur si je prends la moyenne
suisse et 260 millions de litres par an
pour la population de l'est du centre
ville de genève c'est un million de
tonnes de co2 qui est émis
alors la ville est là également elle va
produire des déchets cent mille tonnes
de déchets solides plus 40 mille tonnes
de déchets organiques et elle a les
opportunités
à genève on a le lac d'une part et puis
d'autre part on a du soleil le soleil
qui éclaire tous nos toitures et si on
transforme la quantité d'énergie qu'on
reçoit tous les jours en litre d'essence
on constate qu'on à 620 millions de
litres d'essence qui nous arrive sur le
toit
chaque jour chaque année pardon et on
voit que on a plus de d'énergie
disponible que l'énergie qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui
alors on s'est posé la question avec mes
collègues et puis des partenaires
industriels de savoir si on pouvait
rendre la ville réellement autonome en
énergie autonome en énergie ça veut dire
qu'on voudrait bien ne plus avoir
d'émission de co2 on voudrait bien ne
plus devoir apporter de l'énergie
on voudrait bien également ne pas devoir
abattre tous les bâtiments et tous les
reconstruire on voudrait bien utiliser
la ville telle qu'elle est et on
voudrait bien évidemment ne pas se
ruiner
alors comment ce qu'on a fait alors en
tant qu'ingénieur la première chose
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va regarder
quels sont les besoins
on n'a pas besoin d'énergie et le mieux
ce serait justement de ne pas en avoir
besoin
donc on va regarder quelle est la
quantité minimum dont on a besoin à
l'euro va appeler la science et la
thermodynamique
alors c'est tellement dynamicien
français qui est carnot a montré que
pour chauffer un bâtiment 21° lorsqu'on
a un environnement qui se trouve un zéro
degré eh bien on a besoin d'acheter une
unité d'énergie pour en délivrer 10
alors ça c'est un élément important
parce que ça nous permet de nous guider
et de nous donner une motivation la
motivation elle se trouve ou si je
regarde la quantité d'énergie que je
dépense dans une très bonne chaudière
qui a 90 % de rendement qui utilise du
gaz dont qui brûlent qui produit du co2
eh bien je me rends compte que pour la
même quantité de chaleur c'est à dire
dix unités
eh bien je dois en acheter 11 la
question qui se pose là c'est de savoir
mais pourquoi ce qu'on consomme dix fois
plus que le minimum que la
thermodynamique nous indique est en plus
en imitant du co2
la réponse elle se trouve dans la pompe
à chaleur alors la pompe à chaleur
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez tous un
frigo chez vous le frigo il fonctionne
sur le principe suivant vous prenez
l'électricité vous à les extraire de la
chaleur pour refroidir l'intérieur du
frigo et vous aller chauffer votre pièce
la pompe à chaleur elle fait exactement
la même chose va prendre la chaleur qui
se trouve dehors et grâce à
l'électricité va augmenter la
température et vous chauffez la
thermodynamique nous dit deux choses la
première chose c'est que plus la
température la température
à laquelle on doit chauffer et basse -
on devra dépenser dépenser d'énergie
c'est pour ça qu'on vous recommande
d'installer des chauffages à basse
température et pas des chauffage à haute
température
la tournée une amitié également que
meilleur plus haute est la température
de la source donc de l'environnement
mieux c'est le problème c'est qu'il faut
trouver cette source
et dans la ville on est très dense on a
plein de bâtiment partout donc c'est
très difficile de faire une seule pompe
à chaleur
d'où l'idée qu'on a développés qui est
de dire on va couper la pompe à chaleur
en deux d'un côté on va utiliser une
pompe à chaleur qui va trouver les
bonnes sources de chaleur dans
l'environnement par exemple si j'ai de
l'eau dans le lac ou dans une rivière ou
bien dans le sol
je vais extraire cette chaleur et puis
j'avais l'a transporté à l'endroit où
j'en ai besoin
et puis là je vais utiliser une deuxième
pompe à chaleur qui va satisfaire juste
le niveau de température dont j'ai
besoin
vous avez un chauffage températures
basses tombe un chauffage à basse
température vous payerez moins que celui
qui est un chauffage à haute température
et l'idée pour transporter la chaleur
c'est d'utiliser le co2 ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va utiliser deux tubes
un tube avec de co2 à l'état liquide un
tube avec un du co2 à l'état vapeur on
va prendre la vapeur et on va la
condenser par se faire en vain de cette
manière là on va délivrer de la chaleur
et on va utiliser une pompe à chaleur
pour arriver la température dont on a
besoin
si maintenant quelqu'un veut être
refroidis je veux prendre le liquide et
je peux les vapeurs et est donc à ce
moment là je vais pouvoir refroidir
directement mais bâtiment maintenant
comme ils sont connectés par un tuyau je
peux aussi refroidir le bâtiment k
besoin d'être refroidit avec le bâtiment
qui a besoin d'être chauffé ce qui me
permet finalement de récupérer déjà pas
mal d'énergie
ensuite on va aller sur le chemin
identifier quelles sont toutes les
bonnes sources de chaleur notons dispose
par exemple l'eau usée qui sort de votre
maison à peu près 20 degrés eh bien elle
peut être utilisée pour chauffer les
chauffer les bâtiments l'eau l'eau du
lac l'eau qui sort de la station
d'épuration ou la géothermie
maintenant j'ai un système qui va me
permettre de
des changes est là l'énergie entre les
différents repreneurs alors un autre
élément très important j'utilise du co2
le cio doit une grande densité
énergétique ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
besoin de gros tuyaux on va pouvoir
mettre des tuyaux dans les trottoirs et
on ne doit pas les enterrer parce que le
co2 ne gèlent ne gèle pas obligé de
descendre très profond et donc on peut
faire des trottoirs préfabriqués qui
permettront de transporter l'énergie
dont vous avez besoin
on a donc un système qu un système
complexe qui nous permet grâce à une
pompe à chaleur de se chauffer qui
permet d'être directement refroidi qui
permet également de faire la
réfrigération dans les centres
commerciaux par exemple on a besoin de
frigo ou de congélateurs qui permet
également de récupérer la chaleur de nos
déchets lorsqu'on va aller brûler et qui
utilise toutes les opportunités offertes
par l'environnement ont maintenant la
question c'est de savoir est-ce que
c'est plus efficace que le système
traditionnel
alors pour ça on a fait une application
c'est un quartier de genève où il ya des
bureaux débattent des logements des
banques des commerces pour ceux qui
connaissaient les plus basses on a
calculé la quantité d'énergie qui était
nécessaire et dépenser aujourd'hui pour
se chauffer et se refroidir ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'on a besoin de 12 unités
d'énergie dit souvent de chaleur et de
gaz naturel et de se vendre
d'électricité ce qu'on peut voir
également c'est que le gaz naturel est
principalement utilisé en hiver alors
que l'électricité tu disais en été pour
refroidir le même système avec le réseau
co2 est bien là besoin que de deux
unités on a fait un facteur 6 oui on a
fait un facteur 6 dans la consommation
énergétique
on a besoin que de 16 % de la quantité
d'énergie qu'on consomme aujourd'hui
sans changer les bâtiments il est
évident que si on isole les bâtiments eh
bien on aura en profitera d'un facteur
multiplicatif supplémentaires alors
évidemment tout le monde nous a dit oui
mais ça va coûter trop cher et la
réponse c'est que oui ça vous coûte très
cher pour le moment en fait le système
que l'on propose et coûtera moins cher
et il sera profitable alors que le
système d'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
profitable
maintenant j'ai fait un truc c'est que
presque atteint mon objectif en réalité
j'ai de l'électricité que je dois
apporter au système donc je suis pas
encore tout à fait autonome
j'ai d'électricité que je la portais en
hiver alors la question c'est de savoir
comment ce qu'on fait l'électricité en
hiver alors on peut la faire avec en
apportant l'électricité de l'extérieur
mais à ce moment là on va émettre
beaucoup de co2 et vous voyez que je
perds déjà pas mal de bénéfices je peux
aussi utiliser des nouvelles
technologies comme par exemple cycle
combiné à gaz qui permet qui a une
meilleure efficacité qui aimait beaucoup
moins de co2 parce qu'il utilise un le
gaz naturel mais je peux également dire
ok ben pourquoi ne pas utiliser les
énergies renouvelables pour entraîner
mes pompes à chaleur le problème c'est
que les énergies renouvelables sont
surtout disponible en été le soleil
brille en été et beaucoup moins en hiver
on peut également utiliser une autre
type de technologie alors le pfl à a
breveté un nouveau concept qui combine
une pile à combustible avec une turbine
à gaz qui est un rendement électrique
qui est de 80 % bien supérieur à la
meilleure centrales à gaz et qui sépare
le co2 gratuitement donc maintenant j'ai
du co2 qui est dans un tube
et ça tombe bien j'ai justement un tube
j'ai de la chaleur résiduelle parce que
j'ai 80 % en grèce 20 % mais ça tombe
bien j'ai quelque chose pour la
transporter vers les utilisateurs
donc maintenant j'ai un système qui me
permet de faire de l'électricité qui me
permet de capturer du co2 et qui me
permet de faire mes besoins de chaleur
mais j'utilise toujours du carburant
fossile parce que j'utilise de gaz
naturel alors là il faut aller retourner
à l'histoire et voir ce que les cadeaux
de mère nature
qu'est ce que la nature nous a apporté
elle en fait la nature nous apporter
deux choses d'un côté on a un trésor
le trésor c'est quelque chose qui ne se
remplit jamais il est là et puis on peut
juste l'utiliser c'est ce qu'on fait on
prend une partie du trésor et on le
brûle pour faire du co2 était dit que ce
n'est pas très content en fait
et puisque vous pouvez constater c'est
que le réservoir était vide et il ya
personne qui le remplit donc ça veut
dire que nos enfants ils ont moins que
ce que nous on a reçu de nos parents
on peut peut-être regarder aussi le
cours de courant le compte épargne le
compte courant et quand il parle de la
nature c'est les énergies renouvelables
et on a là deux différentes sortes
on a du soleil on a du vent on a de
l'eau et on a de la biomasse la biomasse
est un peu le compte épargne parce que
elle elle est disponible sous forme
stocker donc je peux pour la biomasse et
je peux maintenant la convertir en gars
et ça ça existe on peut il ya des
procédés biologiques ou des procédés
chimiques qui permet de convertir la
biomasse en gaz si elles sont pas si le
procédé n'est pas efficace il va libérer
la chaleur et géant tuyaux qui permet
d'utiliser la chaleur donc ce sera
parfait si j'ai besoin de salles de
chaleur et le gaz je vais pouvoir
l'utiliser dans les piles à combustible
alors je vais aussi essayer d'apprendre
de la nature réussi je réfléchis bien
j'ai besoin d'énergie ou est ce que je
trouve l'énergie dans la nourriture et
la nourriture c'est l'énergie qui est
stockée je ne sens pas les variations du
soleil qui varie de grandeur et de
saison en saison
comment ce que la nature ait réalisé ça
elle a fait la photosynthèse et la prix
du co2 dans l'atmosphère
elle a utilisé les photons qui venait du
soleil elle a utilisé de l'eau et elle a
fait des hydrates de carbone qui sont en
fait ma nourriture ou qui sont aussi les
arbres on peut faire la même chose avec
un système technique je peux prendre le
soleil je peux le transformer en
électricité avec des cellules
photovoltaïques je peux prendre ces
cellules photovoltaïques ajoute prendre
du co2 et de l'eau et faire du méthane
est ce que je vais faire je prends le
co2 que du co2 que j'ai stocké et je
vais faire du méthane à l'état liquide
que j'ai stocké et je veux voir un
système qui va devenir un peu complexe
parce qu'on était je vais prendre du co2
liquide et je vais faire du méthane
liquide avec le soleil qui brille et en
hiver je vais prendre le méthane liquide
et je vais faire passer dans la pile à
combustible pour produire l'électricité
dont j'ai besoin pour me chauffer et
pour m'éclairer
et je vais capter le co2 le ramener dans
mon tuyau et le convertir en co2 liquide
alors si je fais ça je vais avoir un
système qui va être super qui va
paraître super compliqué mais n'oubliez
pas que vous avez
chez vous tous les jours plusieurs clio
carrie vous avez le câble d'électricité
vous avez le câble internet
vous avez aussi l'eau potable et l'eau
usée qui quittent de chez vous donc
rajouté un tuyau n'est pas
nécessairement si compliqué que ça
on a un système qui permet de chauffer
de l'eau froide ire de réfrigérer de
valoriser tous nos déchets et de stocker
l'énergie solaire que l'on va produire
sur toutes nos toitures en été pour la
rendre disponible en hiver si je fais ça
et bien j'ai un système qui va devenir
entièrement autonome en énergie
avant j'avais un système qui brûlait un
grande quantité d'énergie pour
satisfaire le besoin et qui mettait
beaucoup de co2 et qui évidemment trésor
aujourd'hui avec un investissement je
dois installer une nouvelle
infrastructure avec des pompes à chaleur
ddd pile à combustible et puis du
stockage
eh bien je vais je vais pouvoir
satisfaire les mêmes besoins j'ai pas
changé les bâtiments je n'ai pas changé
votre confort vous aurez toujours la
même température dans toutes vos pièces
vous aurez simplement des panneaux
solaires sur le toit
vous aurez simplement des piles à
combustible qui vont produire de
l'électricité à base du méthane qui a
été produit pendant l'été vous allez
récupérer la chaleur de l'eau chaude que
vous avez envoyé à l'égout parce que
vous vous allez pouvoir l'utiliser dans
les pompes à chaleur
vous allez récupérer l'énergie de vos
déchets et à la fin en fait vous serez
exportateur d'électricité d'une
électricité sur commande c'est à dire
que vous pourrez décider quand vous
voulez exporter vous en avez trop et
elle est stockée en fait sous forme de
méthane
pour la petite histoire la quantité de
stockage qui est nécessaire est dix fois
plus petite que la quantité des citernes
qui sont nécessaires et qui sont tous
les bâtiments
si on chauffe avec si on chauffer tout
avec du mazout et ce sera ma conclusion
en tout cas tedx peut nous dire merci
parce que si
vous êtes capable de transformer la
ville en un producteur nette
d'électricité sans émission de co2 eh
bien il a peut être une chance de
retrouver un autre bloc de glace plus et
coeur merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]